here we at it again
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Music]
and i got a bunch of topics and another
segment of
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but i do appreciate everybody who
watches a podcast
i really love it continue watching
[Music]
all right we're done enough of that
enough roofing with griffin
okay everybody uh we're back at it again
oh let me look at my notes
you know i do take notes i know
sometimes people feel like i'm just
winging it but
i do have some notes for this week's
episode um so
what's going on this week uh let me
something happened this week
i'm really mad about i don't know who
all you mac users out there but
hopefully this will help you out but
first uh thank you for watching please
subscribe share and all that kind of
stuff
i really do appreciate all that your
comments and all that kind of stuff and
remember i do game
every day on twitch that's eric griffin
gaming and i'm partnering with
i partnered with check mate gaming they
put on all those like
tournaments for all different kinds of
games but
they do a lot of war zone call of duty
tournaments
two on two tournaments solo tournaments
you know quads tournaments
it's really fun you know there's cash
prizes
uh but checkmate gaming so there's a
link down below so please click that
link and sign up because i got my own
error griffin gaming tournament coming
up and so i want as many people
and it's going to be free entry and
there's a 250 prize so make sure you
look out for that
that's checkmategaming the link is below
but anyways thanks for watching and
subscribing and all that kind of stuff
um
anyways so i had this issue with my
computer
it's a disaster that i'm still dealing
with right now all right
it's just like just to tech issues with
eric griffin each week or something
right so this week's tech issue is so
here's something at the mac
i have an imac and i use it for
everything and but here's the thing
if you if the if the imac fills up
let's say you're almost done with your
space i have one terabyte and like if
you're almost
filled filled up you the computer won't
restart
like this is like a major thing so
you'll run and everything's fine but say
you have to restart for some whatever
reason
your computer will not restart it won't
restart in safe mode it won't restart in
recovery mode
and you think something's wrong with it
you run the disk utilities nothing shows
up it says it's fine
then it says say disk utility doesn't
work they tell you well why don't you
reinstall the software but here's the
thing
you can't reinstall the software because
you don't got enough space
available excuse me so the trick i found
this is great so if you have an external
drive even if it's like a little
even if it's like a little usb drive
like this for say which i should have
used this i wish i would have
uh you can install a
a different system saw another system on
an external drive
and then you can load up the computer
and then the internal drive you can
manipulate it you can now move things
off of it to create enough space right
so i did this i actually
i used an external drive right
but here's what happened the external
drive i used the [ __ ] mac
software it erased it first then put
and i did not see that as an option like
normally you just think okay there's
plenty of space on this drive just
install the system software on whatever
you know on the empty space
no and i needed everything on this damn
drive so now i'm in this like situation
where i'm like
oh my god i need but you know i need
that stuff so i gotta either take it to
one of these disk places i'm running
some kind of software on it right now
that i found that i'm gonna have to pay
whatever much money for to see if it
works
but if not i lost so much important
stuff and it just really
[ __ ] frustrates me so that's my
computer
issues of the week you know just it's so
freaking annoying so any
certainly mac users out there people mac
experts you want to help me out or like
give me some advice for that kind of
stuff i've already gotten advice from
people on my game stream who are always
like yo man you gotta
you know you gotta just take it into
like a disc recovery place and have the
professionals do it so you don't lose
anything more or overwrite anything so
i'm dealing with that rachel update
rachel update now uh you know rachel's
fancy yo
she fancy okay even if she didn't grow
up fancy and she didn't she's just fancy
she
she was rachel's been a model for like
15 years not bragging it's just helped
spit the story
okay you know so she's she she likes
fancy things she likes fancy dresses she
likes fancy stuff right so
she loves to shop she loves to get
things you know she spends her money on
that and i'm fine with it you know it's
not like i'm spending all my money you
know what i mean it's like that i know
that's what y'all think but that's not
the situation
you know i just tell her i'll take care
of these things you take care of the
things that you uh you know that make
you happy you know what i mean
anyways so like i said she fancy look
i'm trying to i'll even show you some
modeling pictures of her you know you
know what i mean like there there she is
you know she's beautiful you know i mean
she's
she's been she she's worn like all the
best stuff at a show stuff she can't
even
afford you know what i mean stuff normal
people even some rich people wouldn't
spend the kind of money that you have to
spend on
ridiculous high fashion outfits right so
she likes fancy things
so like she made me buy these towels you
know she said we needed new towels
because she moved in
so she's slowly getting rid of all my
stuff because that's what they do they
infiltrate
then they slowly get rid of things like
the bathroom
i don't even recognize it anymore right
like the little things i had in the
bathroom that i thought oh this is
important
all that [ __ ] gone i go in there now and
i think i'm in the at the hilton like
what happened to the bathroom you know
but that's what they do it's fun they
make you better
so she wants new towels so she keeps
throwing away the older this one's
scratchy let's get rid of it
i just gave up i'm just like cause like
why do i have sentimental value on a
towel right
a lot of my towels i steal from hotels
anyway because i'd be on the road i'd be
like i like this big white towel i steal
it
you know so anyways i go
this is a mistaken man i said just you
order what you think is good
and i'll take care of it you know we'll
take care of it later you know because
we're both using them you know
man she gets like some 40 50 apiece
towels
so at first and this is what i do my
move is to be like that was
irresponsible we can't
afford to you know get a towel like that
you know what i mean and then later
you know i the towels come and after
like two weeks i'm like oh i can't live
without these towels
right so we spent some money on these
stupid towels
now here i am talking about it like on a
public forum
you know like even now so even now
somebody might be listening and being
like damn we're in a quarantine i'm
struggling i'm on
uh government assistance or whatever
your situation is and you might be like
well damn how are you talking about
spending 50
on some towels but you know see this is
goes back
okay let me continue because this is
what happened so
i'm on my stream now rachel's tall she's
like six
one and she got a tall a big inseam on
her
jeans so she can't wear regular jeans
so she's on some website and she's like
i finally found some jeans that fit from
some store in rodeo drive
these fit i went to the store i tried
them on this is the only place i can
find jeans but they're 800
800 i can't justify it in my head right
so i go i'll find you some jeans i go
online
i can't find jeans like i swear to god i
went to like 10 websites
it says tall women you know you go you
put in tall
women tall inseam every place you go
they think tall is 34. you know they
just
and the ones that do there was one
they're out of stock
then there's another one it doesn't you
know it i you couldn't find the right
sizes waist i was like wow it actually
really is difficult to find these genes
right so
with the big back and forth i'm live on
my stream
gaming i'm a little bit annoyed because
i'm trying to play and she's coming in
asking me about stuff
so i just go you know what i'll get you
the damn jeans you know i break down i
go you know what it makes you happy i'll
get you these jeans and so i'm going
so i even put a pole up with my my
people i go should i get her the jeans
is it worth it and then you know people
you know people are answering the poll
we're having this fun back and forth
because i stream every single day now
for like two months
so there's like a core group of people
that always come on they've kind of
gotten to know me
so we got this little back and forth
going they know my moods they know when
i'm a bad
in a bad mood or a good mood because i
see it in the chat they'll be like oh
griff's on one today
so you get you kind of get this
camaraderie with people but you have to
remember that
i have to remember the [ __ ] still is
public for
everyone so we have this whole thing
i bought a jeans i tell the people i go
you know but you guys are actually
buying it because you could you know all
you subscribers that subscribe to my
thing and you pay me every month for
subscriptions
i'm using that money to buy her you know
i say [ __ ] like that anyway i get some
comment from somebody who's like
how insensitive you insensitive views
you know to do this and like you know a
lot of us are struggling and you're just
spending 800
on jeans all right let me respond to
this
like just two ways to look at this one i
could be a dick about it and be like
well i'm supposed to act like i'm poor
over here i'm not supposed to live my
life
no that's you think about that even
after even saying it even as an example
is like
that's not what i mean it's just
i'm sorry if people are struggling out
there i i i want everybody to have a
happy healthy life
this is how i live my life you know i'm
frugal in some areas
and i save up and i've worked hard my
entire life so i have the ability to be
like
in a pandemic i have money saved because
i'm like that i'm frugal
i i'm always prepared that i'm never
going to work again
so i saved my money and i still and i
but i also like to enjoy life
so for the people out there that took
offense and are feeling like oh man what
about
you know how that made you feel my
apologies
not did not mean to make anyone feel bad
because like i was trying to say
earlier you forget that even though you
have this
intimate relationship with the people
watching you that you
you have to remember it's still public
so people grab it who
maybe they haven't been maybe this is
their first time and they come on and go
wow that was a little off-putting
and that's what happens when podcasts
anyway it goes into this idea of like
how people
grab your thoughts and feelings and then
they from like the past
and then they use it against you out of
context that's what happens with
podcasts you know
like you're on a podcast every single
week with someone and you know
there's a certain voice you have and
there's a certain you know way of you
carry yourself
and then something happens in the in
them
in the in the public eye some social
thing happens and then people look
through your podcast and they grab a
snippet and go oh look at this
this is inappropriate or this is how
these people feel about what's going on
i mean that's what happened with like
even with like the chris deleah
and brian callan and all this stuff
they're going back on people's podcasts
and going oh look how they were talking
about this
which is completely unfair completely
out of context because
you don't know how these people joke
with each other but at the same time
i do understand that if you're just
coming in fresh
you're coming in and you hear some
things that you go well what's going on
here because that didn't sound right
it's not necessarily up to that person
to be like well i better go listen to
the back catalog of a hundred episodes
so i can understand where these people
are coming from
but you know and at the same time on
your side of it too you got to be like
hey
let me i'm coming into it's sort of it's
it's a public private conversation
that's what's weird about like
podcasting you know and uh streaming and
stuff you know it's a public private
conversation it's
so weird you know so there's like a it's
nuanced you know it's one of my favorite
words it's a double-edged sword
but i think that's what happened in that
situation so
where i do i am sympathetic to everybody
that's struggling out there we're all
trying to do our hustle you know we all
got to hustle we're trying to do and
listen we all we have to enjoy the
comforts in life you know too
uh you know we're just cooped up here my
girl goes to work she comes back and
we're just here
you know it gets boring it gets like her
thing and she likes to shop she likes to
look online and stuff and we go on walks
but it's not enough it's not our regular
life
i'm not justifying it you know i
i'm not trying to justify to say that
you don't deserve to feel the way you
feel
but i also want you to understand my
perspective you know daddy's doing all
right
you know what i mean what am i supposed
to do you know well what i'm supposed to
do is like
be more sensitive to like what i say on
this public forum is basically
the message i'm getting from all this
but again
it's iffy it's a double-edged sword so
that's that
all right uh what else is happening so i
went on a couple of i went off three
podcasts uh in last week
i don't know when they're coming out but
i went on gary owens podcast so look out
for that
gary and i gary we always have a fun
conversation uh he's a fun dude to be
around
so that we you know that was good so
look out for gary's podcast
uh then i went on um that which already
came out i went on fighter and a kid
which my goodness i can't believe the
amount of
i can't believe the equal amount of hate
and love i've gotten from being on that
podcast
i mean the the and this is what i'm
saying about how you know it's like an
intimate relationship with the core fans
because
excuse me every time i come over here i
get heartburn
i shouldn't ate before i came on but
these people
like they have an intimate relationship
so they're going through this whole
thing about
where's brian and we don't like the new
host
we don't like the gas it's like a whole
thing of back and forth and then like
joshua
who was my dear friend we get into it
when we start talking about stuff so we
got into this whole thing
about sports you know he he's
he thinks that athletes
know who's better than them and they
would never say you know they would
never think they're better than like
some of the best
player and you know and i disagree i i
think that if you're one of the starters
of a team
i don't care who that other person is on
the team there's an ego
there's a delusional eagle maniacal
feeling that
that these pro athletes anyways we got
into this big thing
all right so then you got these people
who are coming and coming and coming and
talking [ __ ] you know
and then it's like it's always the same
kind of comments like you do
you what do you know you've never played
a sport uh actually i did play
basketball even if it was just high
school basketball i played i wasn't
always
just i wasn't always a you know a big
fat guy you know what i mean
i was athletic at the time take a look
at the picture don't hate son
daddy had hops too i used to be able to
dunk
i had a great eye i loved playing
basketball in high school but anyway i
did play sports so
you know all these haters that come at
you then they attack you personally this
is the thing i don't understand like
you don't like me fine you disagree with
my opinion
but these troll ass fans man they always
got to go to the worst you're
you're an idiot you know you're you know
what i mean like
you've never played a sport what do you
know it's like the things that they say
about you
you know and i love going back at these
people on twitter you know i just
just say something i say something back
like [ __ ] you you know what i mean
like like honestly i don't give a [ __ ]
about you
you know but it's funny to like interact
you know like it's it's
i don't know it's just you can't win for
losing you know
some people would say never respond
don't give him anything
but the other thing i say well i'm
helping this person you know
they're reaching out you know they
sometimes people want that kind of
acknowledgement of being like
i i was heard so i'm letting you know
you were heard and i don't give a [ __ ]
about it
i'm helping you out you know what i mean
but i don't know
it was a weird appearance that wasn't
i'm saying it wasn't a weird appearance
it was a weird response
and i don't know what's going on with
their podcast or when
they're coming back if brian's ever
coming back or if like it's just a whole
thing and then like and the fans are so
they're just they won't let it go it's
just all this opinions and talk about it
so
but i feel for brendan he's in a tough
situation that's a tough spot to be in
you know because you got like the court
of public opinion and then you have like
all the article
articles will come out you know you just
don't know what's the right answer i
wish it was so easy i wish it was a
black and white answer but it's not
you know because they got people that
paid they got like a patreon fan base
that is huge something like 8
000 people you know compared to my
12 you know what i mean i do have a
patreon you know if you want to help me
out but
you know it's it's so so they got behind
the paywall they got brian behind the
paywall
uh still doing a version of the podcast
but it's like you know
that's a difficult situation and it's
just like the fans just don't care they
just
only all they care about is what's in
front of them and they're just gonna be
crazy about it so i had that appearance
and then
the other appearance which probably i
don't know when it's coming out or if it
maybe it already came out or it's coming
out the same day as mine is coming out
but i did bad friends
i saw my good friends bobby and andrew
so we had a i had a fun appearance on
that one so make sure you check that one
out
but you know watch finish watching this
one before you just switch over
okay so there's that
so that was fun so what else i want to
talk about is the nba man the nba is i
haven't talked about it up to this point
but they're knee deep in the playoffs my
clippers
lost today you know i just think that
dallas mavericks man they just they're
just ready they're primed and ready
this bubble the bubble right now
i love it i i it's to me it's really
pure
basketball and it's showing who's got
the ego who's got the the the
wherewithal who's who can
overcome the circumstances and just be
raw competitive this raw competitive pro
athlete that it's just about winning
it's about
conquering what's happening on the court
i think some of them are treating it
like a job
with their effort and there's some that
are just like really going at it because
there's no motivation other than
monoi mono of the your team versus that
team it's like a
it's like being at the park man and
whoever you have to lose to get off the
court it feels like that kind of feeling
and i
love that and i think the nba is doing a
good job the product looks great
it looks like regular you know look it
looks the same they got that ambient
noise in the
like it seems like it's still in the
stadium going on you don't notice it
but if you really think about it like
hey what's that noise they're at a gym
right they got that they got the screens
on the wall where you can see the fans
it just it feels like
they're going to survive the quarantine
and the pandemic it feels like the sport
can continue
i said on fighting the kid i don't think
that football
is going to last like that and but we'll
see baseball's actually the one
that will will show you that there's no
bubble
they're they're they're going you know i
don't i haven't heard too much about
other than the marlins i haven't heard
too much about if
other players have gotten corona and
what's happened if they've canceled
games
because i don't think people care like i
honestly don't think
who's watching baseball i'm not watching
baseball i don't know who the people are
that are watching baseball but
to me i think baseball's in trouble so
and if baseball can work then possibly
football can work but i don't know if
football can work without a bubble
that's what i'm concerned about because
there's so many players and so many
people so many interactions and they're
like
right up in each other's grill they
think they're trying to figure out a way
to have a mask maybe they'll have like a
helmet that's covered
i don't know i don't know they'll have
to figure that out but it just doesn't
seem like it can work but
hopefully it will because i know we all
love football that football is the
number one
you know and then um this thing in the
nba you know they got
like you know what's funny how no one's
making a big deal about this no one
really cares
about the jerseys with the phrases on
them about the black lives matter on the
court
like all of the social injustice sort of
like things they're trying to point out
no one cares you know why no one cares
it's because
so the sport that is probably 90 black
yeah they think black lives matter like
duh
you know like it's kind of like you go
all right you're preaching to the choir
we get it
what's next like i don't know if like
it's it has the impact that they thought
it would
i don't think anybody i think they're
just kind of like whatever the
announcers don't mention it
i mean maybe they were even kneeling
during the national anthem
nobody cares because at this point we go
yes i know
police brutality is terrible we saw it
we're already past
that okay we're past it we saw the
george floyd tape
and we're now at a point where we're
like hey what's the real change that's
gonna happen
so all these little gestures no one
gives no one cares
i think we're past the gestures it's
time for legislation it's time for
real change okay that
and so until we see the real change
stuff all this other stuff is just
white noise you know it's just noise so
that's i'm not going to go into too much
detail about that but that's just how i
feel about it
i just like i say just to say one more
time i want real change i want to hear
that
laws are being changed i want to hear
that yeah the police's uh police
department is
you know starting a new program to make
sure the cops are more sensitive
in in the neighborhoods like you know i
feel like the cops should go into
neighborhoods man and like
don't just go when things are bad you
got to go when things are good you know
gary owen and i talked about this on his
podcast so
i think we got to stop so like the cops
got to stop
dehumanizing the people that they're
going on these calls for you they hear
some domestic violence or they hear like
something they got
they got to know who these people are
you know uh they got to come into the
neighborhoods
when times are good and we have to stop
treating the cops like they're just some
soulless monsters too we call them for
help and
but they are human beings too so we we
have to treat them better and then they
have to treat us better
like those are the kind of changes like
how can we make those things happen
i don't give a [ __ ] about the back of
your jersey like that ain't doing [ __ ]
for me
okay that's just how i feel about it the
one thing about the nba though this
reboot that is
weird to me i love that they got the
fans on the wall that was a genius idea
have people zoom the zoom or facetime or
whatever that
technology is where they can be on the
screen
what i don't like about it is people
should be uniform
like like make the dimensions for
everybody the same i can't stand you see
the wall
and then somebody's head is like bigger
than everybody else it's like just a
head on the screen
another person's little it just looks
it's distracting and weird to see
everybody like with these different
sized heads
that's that's just me i obsess about
little things like that
and i can't stand that you know like
what's this chick's big head
like i have a picture i'm gonna i'm
gonna show you guys yeah you why i
probably already put it up i don't i
don't know what
it's going to look like when i finally
put the thing together but like if you
look at that
look at that girl's big ass head just
it's just
like she's sitting next to somebody and
make the other dude look like he's
little like she's a giant
i just think that looks weird then that
little kid is in the back
i just like to me that [ __ ] is
distracting
like it should be uniformed that's just
my little
weird take on that make the [ __ ]
uniformed man
you know what i mean right and then when
they had this situation so the
the dallas mavericks in the los angeles
clippers
series is really good i'm not going to
be surprised if dallas wins
to me i think they're primed for to win
in the bubble
they got a young hungry team with two
superstars
they're lengthy they're fast they play
defense and they can score at will
they got interior interior defense you
know
i just think that they i'm not gonna be
surprised if they beat the clippers and
then they go on
to do something great because they're
primed and ready for it and that luca
man he's good
he's real good so so luka doncic he's a
the foreign star
for the point guard for the dallas
mavericks and then montrez harold from
the clippers
they had they were getting into it and
montres herald called him
now listen in normal circumstances you
we probably wouldn't even heard about
this or even cared
but because they're in the gym and the
cameras are picking things up
and you know the cameras are always on
the players and you can't get away from
it in a situation like that
mantra's harold called him a bitch-ass
white boy
bitch-ass white boy right
all right so now what happens
so we have all this rachel t racial
tension we got the
black lives matter on the on on on the
floor
you know we got this racial injustice
going on in the country and we bring it
all in light to it
and then this happens so it makes white
people go
well look at this listen this [ __ ] ain't
the same
all right just straight up it's not the
same
white boy has never the word saying
calling somebody a white boy
has not enslaved them it's not used as a
slur
to you know make you feel less than a
human being
all right it's just one of those terms
i'm not saying this right i'm not trying
to justify it i think manchester
should have apologized i think they
should have squashed that
but i just don't like the idea of people
thinking that this is on the same level
as if he called him a monkey-ass m-word
okay it's not the same it's not the same
at all
the racial connotation like the worst
part about calling him a bitch-ass white
boy is that he called him a [ __ ]
so you called the dude a [ __ ] and then
you caught him a boy
but the white part
did that make him feel bad the way
if if you the way these other racial
slurs
the hate that comes behind those racial
slurs that this is it's not the same
it's just it's just not the same it's
not the same connotation at
all and by the way in this circumstance
lucas killing them you know and then the
guy he said it in frustration
it's an old school thing like in a sport
that's predominantly black
and then for the white athlete is first
of all the american born white athlete
is non-existent okay you you go ahead
look it up
you you right now as i'm saying this to
you right now
without going to google i want you to
name me
five american-born white
basketball players who are starting in
the nba
starting think about it right now go
ahead let me give you a moment
i know it's hard right you go uh there's
always another starter
you know you got gordon haywood kevin
love
i mean i i'm lost after that
american-born
basketball players so the white athlete
the white athlete in the nba that
[ __ ] uh that you want to talk
about minority
so it's not even rel
like luca has been playing basketball
his whole life he went to basketball
academy or whatever like
those euro he should have if he would
have called him euro trash that would
have been better
you trash euro you know but that's just
like [ __ ] talk that don't mean anything
the dude got 40 points you know what i
mean he's killing him
so i'm glad they squashed it but i don't
appreciate
like people that are trying to make it
more than it is don't make it more than
it is
don't put it on the same level don't try
to compare it don't try to be like you
know well you know if it was all
if it was a y player that called
somebody such and such you're a [ __ ]
idiot if you think if that's the analogy
you're trying to make
those two things are not equivalent not
excusing montrez harold because he's
just you know it's you know
because it's the optics of it you know
it's like when you're having a private
conversation with somebody and you say
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] but it's private
between you two
if somebody hears that you can't be mad
that somebody like
overheard or somebody recorded it and
released it you could be mad about that
but at the same time you have to be like
i'm sorry that
the words that i said hurt you they got
out i didn't think it was going to get
out
it's like that baseball and oh that's
right this just happened the baseball
announcer used the f word you know the
derogatory homosexual slur i'm not gonna
say it here you know
he used that you know he didn't know he
was on air you know what i mean
he just was like uh you know he making
some joke off-handed joke
right and he came back to air and then
they told him later yo
bro you kind of said and you saw him man
he was so
dejected he just was like he knew too he
was like he even said well this is
probably the last time i'm
gonna be sitting in this seat uh
you know all you could do is apologize
like the things we say in private
the things we say to people that we
think only this person is hearing
sometimes it could be some awful [ __ ] i
don't think it's always people's heart
you know i don't always think that you
got to take it with a grain of salt or
how it was said or
what's the circumstances of what you're
saying you know if you're making a joke
or if you're just saying some off-handed
thing
you know or even you know it's just
private between you and another person
but then when that goes public and
people hear that
you know you have to apologize for it
but you just hope that i hope the guy
can you know overcome i mean
it's just an unfortunate situation you
know you gotta you know you gotta be
more professional you gotta watch what
you say in these settings i mean it's
just like now you realize even on
podcasts going back to what i was
talking about before
you know you say something on your
podcast kind of like thinking ah i got
what five thousand people are listening
to this
but then i get trying to get hired at
some movie or something and then they
somebody's looking back and going
oh you know what the person you're
trying to hire they said this and we
don't like it so we want them removed
from society
you know that's the kind of that's the
kind of culture we live in right now
it's an example of cancer culture
i mean you know i don't think the guy
should be fired
hey you suspend him for a few games you
know the guy should live with the shame
of it
you know he should he said that he went
i think the punishment enough was him
having to be on air
being like damn i shouldn't have said
that i'm so sorry i feel embarrassed and
and how he dealt with it i forgot the
guy's name you know you guys could look
it up
baseball announcer says whatever i
probably that i just came with that off
the cuff i wish i would have wrote that
down in my notes and i would have
something more prepared for it but
it is what it is so [ __ ] ass white boy
you know wrong uh because
he's cursing people heard it but please
don't
have the idea that that is on the same
level as some
derogatory term towards you know someone
of color it's not
so stop it
all right guys now it's time for my
favorite
new segment which is i'm not gonna call
it a segment anymore it's just what the
show is now
and it is real world advice from a grown
ass man
here we are guys real world advice from
a grown ass man
is back again and i got some you know
some i think some of them are gonna have
been a little too heavy but they're
still heavy
and i try to answer on instagram and
i've gotten a couple of videos
this time i think i'm gonna play one of
the videos but if you want to send your
messages a video because even when you
send it to me on instagram
i actually write the person and go i'm
going to use this on my podcast would
you like to send a video
you know so first one is what's your
take on dating
apps well i mean i i love dating apps
not anymore but i said i like the idea
of dating apps because
but here's my thing on dating apps start
on a dating app
put out a wide net narrow it down meet
some people talk to some people
but use it as an introduction but get
off that [ __ ] right away
so you even if you're swiping on tinder
or
you know some especially bumble like if
bubba is looking for because bumble's
all about the
women making the first move which i
think is crazy like i think that's like
you know
i don't think it's crazy but i think
there's a lot of women who are like i
don't want to make the first move
so i think this just makes men lazy i
loved being on bumble back in
when i was single because it's just like
all right who then you you actually know
who's interested in you
you know what i mean it makes it easier
for men you know we don't have to like
you know take that that leap
so anyways if you meet somebody get off
the app
start talking and be like hey can we
facetime can we talk on the phone
meet up right away you know or if they
need some time but i think you should
just use it as so i think dating apps
are great for an introduction
but i think you should move towards
getting off of it asap
uh you know move towards you know
getting some real contact and connection
so you can actually find out if this
person is
interesting or not so that's that one
best
approach on telling a friend you like
them more than just a friend
i get this question a lot you know i
think almost every week someone has some
form of this question but look
i think that when you're really close
with
a friend of the opposite sex or even the
same sex and
in you in your in your and you have uh
your
if you you're a homosexual whatever
you're you know gay lesbian
whatever that sort of friendship you
have with someone um
whether it be straight or like i say i
think that you guys know
like you know when somebody has more
feelings for you
but there's something that feels good
about that attention you're getting from
this person because you do care for them
they're your friend
you know they're they and so you love
that friendship
and you love this sort of extra
attention you're getting from this
person that you call your friend you're
being selfish
like when you know somebody has more
feelings for you you're being selfish
because you really
cherish that friendship so the best
approach is just to deal with it
now you have to decide for yourself what
do you want out of this like
are you okay with this person being your
friend and by the way that is okay
it is okay to decide that someone you
are attracted to
it's okay to be like i am attracted to
you man you are my
type but i really value our friendship
more it's okay to make that choice but
deal with it
like don't pretend you don't have those
things because once you put it out there
y'all can deal with it
you know not to be in certain situations
and it'll help you like
get past those feelings and have a
really
like nurturing beautiful
friendship that will be long-lasting you
know it will be long-lasting it can be
i mean i'm telling you it can be so
like i say my my the best approach i can
tell you is to go ahead and like
make make the move either decide i don't
want to just be your friend so i got to
put that out there
and then you have to decide for yourself
if you can't be just a friend with this
person
then you got to get the [ __ ] out but
give that person the opportunity to say
yay or nay because then you'll know what
you need to do
right so don't be a coward and
make the move i play a lot of war zone i
play a lot of call of duty
war zone call of duty so somebody said
what's your call of duty strategy to win
a battle royale solo i call it slow
aggressive
that's my style i'm slow aggressive
so i'm slow when i move but then i'm
aggressive when i see people
or i'm aggressive in them in the
location that i want to get to
so i like to work the outside of the
circle i like to be up high in buildings
you know i like to i like to listen but
you know i'm not big on heartbeat
sensors even though a lot of people use
them i feel like people it becomes a
crutch
that you die holding that heart your
character is holding that heartbeat
sensor
right i don't like gas masks because the
gas mask animation has killed me
numerous times
so i just like to stick and move i like
to go slow
aggressively slow aggressively
work the circle but if you want to find
out more you have to watch my gaming
videos on
eric griffin gaming on twitch and i
sometimes go live on youtube but i put a
lot of my videos on youtube
at eric griffin gaming also so i do play
a lot of call of duty
like i said earlier make sure you join
the checkmate gaming
click that link it's on my instagram
profile it's on my website
i gotta make sure it's on my way it's on
my website um eric griffin.com
and it's on the on the comments below
here all right on the uh
in the information below here click that
checkmate gaming link and sign up for
checkmategaming
it's free to sign up and it's gonna be
free to join my tournaments
my first tournament the rest of them
they're gonna be probably be like our
credit but you'll see
just go on there but anyway that's my
strategy for now
any advice on dealing with long-term
regrets regret is a terrible thing
and i'm not one of these people that you
know you say you shouldn't regret
anything you know
things happen for a reason i don't
believe in that [ __ ] either i think it's
okay to have regret
as long as how you as long as how you
deal with it is
you regret this if if it's something
that you can't
fix or do better that's motivation to do
it better
you might sometimes you have regrets and
you can't do anything about it so
in that case you have to recognize that
this is
now out of my control i made a mistake
i should have done such and such and i
didn't so now all you could do is live
your best life after that
but personally for me i started doing
comedy in my early 20s
i started by going to open mics and
stuff but i didn't know how to do it
i didn't have the wherewithal i just i
just was i didn't have the
like i just was cowardly about it i just
i didn't know i didn't take the time to
to do all the things i needed to do
i always regret that i always look back
and go
dammit i wish i would have stuck with it
when i was 22
and not wait till i was 30. you know i
always regret that but i've
used that regret to push myself
to make it make myself feel like well i
gotta catch up
and so i've worked hard to get myself to
this point that i'm at now
and even i still even could have done
more but
i don't think there's anything wrong
with having regret
it's actually how you process and deal
with it that's the important
part that's you living your life so good
luck
how do i deal with my close brother who
can't seem to quit alcohol
he's lost everything man you know i
talked about
this a little bit on fighter and the kid
and i'll talk about it again now that's
tough i have a close
really close friend of mine who
has had this problem with alcohol
and it's tough because when you love
someone
dearly it's hard to watch them
self-destruct
and not think you can help and do
something
but what you come to realize is you
become an enabler
you know you enable them to continue
this behavior because
because of your love for them you don't
allow them
to deal with the consequences of their
actions
because you try to clean it up and save
them from themselves
but the thing that has to happen is they
unfortunately
have to deal with like i say the
consequences of their actions
if they get kicked out of their place if
they've lost whatever whatever that is
you have to find a way to do as minimal
amount as possible
or at least let them have to deal with
it
because that's going to be the only
thing that's going to make them go
oh [ __ ] i have nothing or
my support system isn't where i want it
to be
because they need that you know these
alcoholics become master manipulators
and they can sniff out an enabler like
this
they can there's always some person like
my friend there's always some person in
his life that he could just
walk all over you know and
because they they they know they can
feel it because they're survivors
you know they're surviving if you ever
wonder that you go you think man they
they've lost everything they lost this
they lost that but somehow they're on
their feet
because that's their way you know they
find a way
but you but your love attention and
affection
if you if you keep it coming at 100 then
what if they lost
they still have you doing everything
that you did before they have to know
that they're gonna lose that
and you can't blame yourself you know
you can't it's not your fault
you know it's not your fault i mean i
can only
i mean that's i just that's all i can
say about that it's just it's not
your fault it's not your responsibility
there's not much more you could have
done
to change it because that person is
their own they're their own person
they have their own demons that they
have to deal with that they have been
trying to deal with
you know and a lot of times it seems
that alcoholism is brought on by
trying to self-medicate themselves from
other pain and trauma
and then they become an alcoholic
because that's the chosen
self-medication
but by the way it's always worse
it'll start with alcohol and then the
next thing you think is just alcohol
next thing you know there's meth and
there's heroin and there's
you know it just turns into something
else because they're you know
so they they haven't been been able to
deal with this pain and anguish that's
going on in their life and that's
that's the hard part because that's the
part of somebody that's a loved one
you're trying to well how can i help
how can i take away that pain how can i
you know and you just you can't
all you could do is try to set them up
and help them
find a way to deal with it but that's
all you could do because that's what
like interventions are
all you can do is offer if you have the
means be like hey i'll help you get into
therapy
you know i you know you you just try
your best effort
but don't make it your responsibility to
fix it
because you won't be able to and that's
just going to drive you crazy
so i know you love this person uh they
know you love them
can i'm not saying continue to love them
but you have to
compassionately detach from the
situation
because they have to deal with the
consequences
of their actions i wish i had a
simple answer and i wish there was a
magic wand i can wave but
it is what it is so good luck with that
here's a good one
should i complete my phd from a very
prestigious school
even though my heart isn't in it
well you know what you're talking about
is sacrifice
so you're already in a position where
you feel like you have a handle on life
i could tell
by this question that you're talking
about if you have the means and
wherewithal
and ability to go to a very prestigious
school
to get this phd that is only going to
further enhance your life
you have to ask yourself do i need this
do i want to benefit
from this additional sacrifice to do
this whether your heart is in it or not
you know we don't like you don't always
have to do things if your heart isn't in
it
if your heart is in it because that's
like short-term
that's that's short-term you know that's
that good feeling you want to have right
now like i just always want to be doing
something that makes me feel good
no you're doing this for the long haul
so like in 10 years you could be like
hey that was tough but i'm so glad i did
that because i'm living this way now
if you don't feel like you're gonna
regret that choice
go ahead and do it you know you already
know the answer to this one you know
what i mean i
i think you know the answer to this so
i think that you should just decide
either you know what i don't need my phd
i think i'm good i think i'm gonna be
okay
uh but if you feel some kind of way
about like i'd love to have my phd i
just don't wanna deal with this
i think you can overcome that i think
you can overcome and deal with that
and realize that you know here's the
outcome
like have some write down your goals and
if your goals are if your end goal is
something that
it would be better with a phd when you
work backwards
you're going to hit this point right now
where you're like oh
let me i have to go do this thing it's
going to take me a few years
it's not going to be the best but i'm
really going to benefit from it later
you have to decide if that's how you
want to go and live your life
good luck here's our video question of
the week
hey eric it's jake and my question for
you is
my fiance and i are 25 and will be
getting married next summer
should we take the next couple of years
to focus on building our careers
or focus on traveling and gaining
experiences
any insight is helpful i appreciate you
a lot
okay this is actually a you know a it's
actually a very interesting question
you know i mean they're 25 they're young
they're about to get married and they're
they're just trying to do
you know should they get experiences or
should they work on their professional
career
and i say why do you have to choose
between them at all
you know why do you have to choose
between them it's just about making
certain sacrifices now
for the long-term goals so it's like
it's so easy to be like okay
we're going to take six months work some
work on our career but we're going to
set aside a week
that this is the week we're going to
build up to going to
you know we're going to go to cabo san
lucas or we're going to go to the
china and go see the wall well not
during this time right now on quarantine
but
you know eventually hopefully the world
gets back to normal we'll be able to
travel but i don't think you have to
i don't think it has to be all or
nothing i think you can do both
and it'll enhance your life i think if
you use like vacation and some great
experiences
as a reward for the hard work in your
careers
then you could be like all right well
you know we're gonna work hard for nine
months but then we're gonna take two
weeks off together to go do this and
then we're gonna get back to it
you young people man you think it's all
or nothing and it's not
it's about incorporating all these
things in your life it's about
managing time it's about understanding
your responsibilities it's about you
know
saving money being responsible and
productive i think you could do
both those things and think you can
enjoy life and work on your career
you know i think you guys i think you
guys are going to be fine it sounds like
you both are like-minded individuals you
both you know
you want the best in life you that's why
you want to have experiences and you
and you you both are goal-oriented
because you're saying like hey we want
to work on our careers
do both you don't have to limit yourself
to one or the other
open your minds young people expand and
realize that there's time enough
in there's time enough in life to have
all the things that you want to have
just enjoy them
each step of the way right
uh all right guys that's gonna be it for
this week's uh episode of
riffing with griffin that was real world
advice from a grown ass man i i really
enjoy doing that
and you know every week i will put up my
instagram post so make sure you follow
me on instagram
eric griffin and uh if you want to send
me the video questions but please
you know send them to me in when i put
that post up
but make sure it's a video on instagram
that i can download you know because
then i download it and then i'm going to
put it on the episode
and you know keep keep things coming you
know just listen i ain't an expert
i'm not a doctor i'm not a professional
i just play one on a podcast
and all i'm doing is just giving you my
thoughts and experiences
take them for what they are you know if
if somehow
i appreciate all the people that are
sending me messages going
how they really appreciate this segment
you know each time i put up a post on
instagram and i respond to it and when i
respond to them on instagram i like how
people are
hitting me up going oh this helped me
and all that kind of stuff and that's
all i'm trying to do is just
spread some love and joy and uh you know
so we can get the we can get the best
out of uh you know our experience here
on this uh
beautiful planet you know and again stay
stay safe out there you know make sure
you wear your masks and wash your hands
and
keep your social distancing so we can
beat this damn
virus and you know this election is
coming up not necessarily trying to be
political
but i will say this don't just think the
vote is about
biden and trump you know what you if you
really care about politics and want to
make a change
you got to make sure the senate you got
to make sure all the the governors
and and congress people like those are
the elections you have to bet on because
that's where the real change is going to
happen
is making sure that your local official
because look
you know trump has a stranglehold on the
republican party so
you know if the if the people in those
districts around the country are like
hey we want to support that then those
people that are there the governors and
those people are going to be like yeah
we support him
but if they get their jobs taken away
then the people that come in are going
to be listening to
the majority of you know whatever those
people want so
it's not just about you voting for the
president it's about voting for all
those other little things
because that's really going to make the
change no matter who you're voting for
if you're if you're voting for
if you want trump to stay in office then
you just stay with what you're doing you
know vote for
that republican governor or whoever else
is you know in your way
the other people don't just talk
non-stop about
trump and biden don't talk non-stop
about that you need to find out who
those local officials are because that's
where the real change comes in
the senate all right guys
uh that's another episode of reverend
with griffin uh i will
see you next week please subscribe and
share and once again remember if you
want i game daily on twitch
that's eric griffin gaming on twitch and
i put those videos up on youtube
and i sometimes stream live on youtube
also at eric griffin gaming on both
places
follow me at eric griffin my website
eric griffin.com
and i appreciate you guys for listening
and
you know being who you guys are every
week so
take care and
goodbye
you